ama ben biraz farklı bir şey anlatmak
istiyorum ve bu Anlatacağım şeye
sonuçlar çağırdım Bu arada sonuçlar
çağının kavramını ve terimini ben bu adı
koymadım versin Churchill koymuş İkinci
Dünya Savaşı'na girerken ve Bence biz
yine bir sonuçlar çağına girmek üzereyiz
Bugünse sor çağını anlatacağım ama bu
kavramı ne anlama geldiğini de anlatmak
istiyorum ama ünlü bir Çin bedduasını
anarak başlamak istiyorum şöyle der bu
Çin bedduası İlgin zamanlarda yaşayasın
gerçekten çok enteresan bir beddua Çünkü
bugün Biz çok İlgin zamanlarda yaşıyoruz
ve bu bildiğin zamanlar biraz daha
ilginç hale gelecek Biz hep beraber
Aslında sonuçlar çağına gireceğiz Bu
lafı da seviyorum Bir lafla başlamak
istiyorum laf diyor ki insanlar ya son
derece bağışlayıcı var ya da kendilerine
ne yaptıklarını açıkça anlamıyorlar
ama ben de bugün aynı soruyu soracağım
ama acaba bir çok mu bağışlıyoruz yoksa
gerçekten başımıza ne geldiğini ve
Başımıza ne geleceğini anlamıyor muyuz
Bendeki kısım dayım Bence anlamıyoruz
onun için benim Bugün birazcık başımıza
kuvvetten sonra neler geleceğini
anlatmak istiyorum Karar sizin bağışı
olmaya devam edebilirsiniz buna
karışmıyorum ama en azından bugün
birazcık anlama noktasında Hayır size
yardımcı olmak istiyorum önce sonuçlar
çağı ile başlayalım sonuçlar çağının bir
kavramını kes pirinç açılı bir kavram
olduğunu söylemiştim çorçıl biliyorsunuz
başbakanla aldıktan sonra Nazilli'de
savaş ilan edilmesi gerektiğini söyler
ki o noktada dakikaya kadar İngiltere
sürekli bir orta yol bulmaya çalışır
nazilerle Winston Churchill en Başbakan
olmasıyla birlikte bu resim değişir ve
Winston Churchill şöyle bir şey söyler o
ünlü konuşmasında parlamentoların Dökümü
konuşmasına der ki artık bu zaman
erteleme zamanı Yarın önlemler zamanı
yatıştırıcı önlemler zamanı
13 hareler gecikmeler yani orta yolu
bulmanın Zamanı Değildir artık biz şeye
girdik sonuçlar çağına girdik bir sonuç
yaşayacağız bu sonuç acunu bizim için
iyi olması veya bizim için kötü olması
tam ile bize bağlı demiştir bizde cawwot
ile birlikte ve komisyon sonraki
sessizlikle yeniden sonuçlar çağına
gidiyoruz Neden öyle oraya girdiğimizde
birazdan anlatacağım ve bizim karar
vermemiz gerekiyor bakımında yatıştırmak
kelimesini söyledim bunu sonra bir daha
yatıştırmaya döneceğim Çünkü orada bir
kitle ile tanımlanmıştır Yapıştırıcılar
demiştir ve Yapıştırıcılar dan bizi
kastetmiştir bizi dedim beni bu
sahnedeki beni ve bu programı izleyen
büyük Oska sizleri birazdan
tamamlayacağım yatıştırıcı ne demektir
ve şunu demeden demişti bu
Yapıştırıcılar artık bu yapıştırmak tam
Vazgeçmek Zorunda var Ben de diyorum ki
İkinci Dünya Savaşı'ndan hazır yok okula
gittiler kuvvetten Sonra yeniden
dünyanın ortak düşmanı var ve bu
Düşmanlar ötelemeler LV yarım çarelerle
uğraşamam
çok acı karar vereceğiz bu komikle
yapıştırıcım olacağız yoksa başka bir
şey mi yapacağız Ben bu sunumun sonunda
Sizi başka bir şeyler yapmaya ikna
etmeyi umuyorum ama tabii ki Karar sizin
yapıştırıcı olmaya da devam
edebilirsiniz koy geldi hiç komedi
konuşurken bu hafta sümüklü şeyden
bahsediyoruz yaşam tarzlarımız an artık
her şeyimiz olmayın kucaklaş almıyoruz
Keşke bu kadar küçük şeyler değişmiş
olsa hayatımızda yani Biz bir araya
gelemiyoruz online da işlerimizi
yapıyoruz birde buna yeni normal diyoruz
ben size göstereceğim Normalde birazdan
Çünkü yeni normal deyince bir de şöyle
bir şey geliyor aklımıza sanki
geçmişimize normal lerle dolu da yeni
Normalde gelmiş gibi bir zaten hiçbir
şey normal olmayan bir ülkede yaşıyorduk
en temelde boyası En azından korkmayın
yeni Normalde gelmeyecek Yeni anomaliler
gidecek 17 Normalde peşine düşmeyelim
bir de anomali Allah aşkına şey gibi
görmedim yani insanlarla bir araya
gidemeyeceğiz kucaklaşan yayacağız
vesaire Ben şimdi birazdan çok daha
dramatik bir anomali den bahsedeceğim ve
emin olur yani onlardan
Ben bunu yanında yani çok büyük problem
olmayacak hiçbirimizin Peki başlayalım o
zaman asla mevzu kuvvetle başlamadı şu
an abi rakamlar göre olmanız lazım
ekranınızda o zaman komidin Evet koy
başa bela Ama komutasında bir şeyin
sebebi değil kötü bir şey hızlandırıcısı
oldu ama bu kötü şey çok daha önceden
başladı aslında çok basit bir konuydu
2008'de 2014 yüz arasında özellikle çok
fazla çok fazla dolar asla hiçbir
desteği olmadan üretilip piyasaya
verilmişti burada görüyorsunuz zaten
datayı göreceksin bakın görüyorsunuz
ekranda 2008 yılında başladı 2014
yılında Pick bir noktaya geldi deli gibi
para üretildi ve piyasalara pompalandığı
ve arkasında hiçbir destek yoktu
birazdan Bu ne demek ve hayatımızdan
komik ile beraber bu bir araya
geldiğinde hayatın nasıl bir değişiklik
olacağını söyleyeceğim sonra bir
kendisine geldi dünya ve durdu 2014 yılı
itibariyle durduk yani bakın
görüyorsunuz şu anda 2008-2014 yılına
kadar
o çoktan bir para üret hiç bir deste
olmayan bir paragraf piyasaya var vardı
sonra 2014'ün da durduk dünya durdu ve
artık biz para pil tipi bıraktık sonra
koli geldi Ne oldu biliyor musunuz
yeniden üretmeye başladık Şimdi
2008-2014 yılına kadar en çok Amerika
feda lazer üretiyordu ama komite beraber
hepimiz üretmeye başladık sa birazdan
Göstereceğim size rakamları Ama zaten
inanılmaz bir nakit para piyasaya
verilmişti sonra durduk birazcık bunu
normalleştirmeye Çalıştık şimdi hep
beraber bütün dünya desteksiz para
üretiyor ve piyasalara veriyor ve bu
komik ile birlikte hayatınızda ne
getirecek Birazdan konuşacağız nereye
gideceğiz Dünya nereye gidecek biz
nereye gideceğiz sorusunun cevabını
vermeye bakacağım ama Timur'un mu bir
senaryosu var zannedersem 2014 yılında
yazdığı bir makale aynı senaryo Bugün de
sizle beraber oynamak istiyorum
seyredenler değil Lütfen çok mantıksız
demeyin
o kadar çok mantıksız ölçü mantık
aramayın bu senaryoda ama birazcık bu
senaryo üstüne düşünmenizi istiyorum
sana çok basit bir şeyden oluşuyor şöyle
bir senaryo var Biz bütün insanlık bir
araya geldik ve elimizde avucumuzda ne
varsa satmaya kaldırdık yani tabağınızı
Çağımız ayakkabımızı bu gömleğin ne
varsa sattık her şeyi dolara döndürdük
çırılçıplak parktayız hep beraber bütün
insanlık bir araya geldik çırılçıplak
oturuyoruz önümüzde bütün paraları
koyduk ne kadar bir para biriktirin
insanların elinde ne kadar para olduğunu
görürüz şey diyebilirsiniz Tabii ki bu
Mantıksız bir senaryo kime satacağız
bütün insanlık satıyorsa kim alacak bir
kişi olsun ona her şeyi alsın ve bize
parasını versin ne varsa hayatımızda
evimizi arabamızı bankanızdaki mevduata
bütün borçları kapatalım ve bütün
paraları alalım çırılçıplak sokağa
çıkalım ve bu dağları saymaya başlayalım
ne kadar para görürüz bir kere elimden
nasıl bir değer oluşur onun cevabını
vereyim size 260 da 270 çocuğun arasında
bir dolap
bu Ortaya koymuş oluruz 260 270 trilyon
dolar şimdi bu paranın arkasında bir
destek olması gerekiyor bir destek ve
üretilmiş olması gerekiyor bu paranın
ben size göstereyim Hani hep derler ya
bunun arkasına bir altında istediği var
söyleyeyim size bugüne kadar dünyada da
üretilmiş madenlerden çıkartılmış altın
dokuz sürüyor 260 270 lira paramız var
Ama bugüne kadar ürettiğimiz altın çok
fazla dokuz siliyor 30 kadar
en uç muşuz bu tamam hiç bir deste yok
koymuşuz makineye basmış basmış basmış
vermişiz basmış basmış vermişiz şimdi
komple beraber bu bizim hayatımda ne
geçecek öncelikle şunu görüyoruz ki
elimizde Aslında temelde bir 270
trilyonluk yığın var ama biz bunları her
şeyi sattığımızda ve bu sistemden
çıktığımızda bu aslında biraz edelim ya
değer burada bir değer yok bizim
elimizde kağıt var 270 TL'ye ekonomide
bizi insanın elinde Tonlarca 270 limonlu
bir kağıt var Tonlarca bir kağıt üzerine
oturttum oturuyoruz Peki bu ne demek o
Tonlarca kağıdımız dönüşte birazdan
komidin ne yaptığını anlatacağım ve bu
hayatımızı nasıl değiştirecek ama uzun
zamandır Dünya çok uzun zamandır devasa
bir kağıt yanın üstüne oturuyor ve buna
ekonomi diyor
bu devasa kağıt var elimizde hepimiz
evinde kağıt var burada halk o kağıda
Tabii ki hakkaniyeti dağıtmamış şöyle
bir örnek verin hakkaniyeti dağıtsa krep
Toplu para eşit olarak görüntü
dönüşseydi bütün dünyada her bireyin 55
bin dolar şu anda para olsa olurdu tabii
ki burada Hiçbirimiz değiliz çünkü
rakamlar birazdan göstereceğim ama Bafa
farketmez hepimizin geçerli bir şey var
O da dünya ekonomisi bir kağıt yanın
üstüne oturtulmuş gibi görünüyor ve
üzerine kolit geldi sadece bir dakika
vereceğim size Amerika komik aylarında
sadece ABD üç buçuk milyon parayı
yeniden filtered verdik yasayı daha çok
yahut yeni üstünde daha çok Kağıt koydum
ve bu sırada sadece ABD bunu yapmadı
bütün dünya yaptı Peki bu ne demek
ve ekonomi diyoruz ama bir saadet
zinciri üstünde oturuyoruz bütün dünya
aslında bir kağıdın peşinde koşuyor bu
kağıdı aslında bir değer değil Çünkü
arkasından bir destek yok birazdan başka
problemleri de anlatacağım elimizde bir
saadet zinciri Var farkında bile değiliz
Peki bu saatte zincirden Biz kötü
etkileniyor çeşitli dönüşüm yok ama
birazdan şey göstereceğim bizden daha
kötü etkilenen bir kitle var şaşırtıcı
olarak dünyanın en zengin kitlesi çok
daha kötü etkilenmiş durumda Çünkü dünya
yağını üstünde otururken onların yığını
bizden daha çok yani ne kadar daha çok
Hatta size bir rakam verim dünyada en
zengin kişilerin ki toplamda dünyanın
100'de 1'ine oluşturuyorlar bu kağıt
yanın yüzdeki kalsın kontrol ettiğini
biliyoruz Ve ilk defa farkındalar ki
sahip oldukları şey Kağıt neden buna
farkına vardı birazdan söyleyeceğim
Çünkü bir Kainat tükendi paranın anlamlı
olması için birşeyde eşitlenmesi
gerekiyor ki
Bu anlamda olmak için altınla
desteklenmesi gerekiyor ama o bir şey
yok olunca o falan sadece bir kağıda
dönüyor bu ise ilk defa dünyanın en
zengin olan yüzde biri puanı yüzde 46'sı
kontrol ediyor ama bu da şu anlama
geliyor Tonlarca olan kağıdın yüzde
46'sı duyan en zengin 100'de 1'ine ait
ve ki bu neden anlamsız hale geliyor
Neden şey diyorum hiçbir şey
kazandırmaya cak onları onlarda artık
farkındalar çünkü gerçekten şu aralar Bu
yüzde Uu bir Ultra zengin parasının
gidecek bir yer yok Zamansız para ilk
defa ve ilk defa dünyada bankalar batıda
paranızı getirseniz dahi ve yatırmaya
kalsa bırakın size mevduat faizi vermeyi
sizden para istiyor Diyor ki Ben bu
parayı depolayacak Sam Bana para
vereceksin çünkü bu paraların artık
gidebileceği projeler yok dünyada bir
şeyle bu parayı eşitliği yemediniz anda
bir yerde bunu kullan ama Kullanıma
koyamadığı zamanda bu paranın sizi hiç
bir an
ne oluyor Hatta blackrock en önemli
yatırım yönetimi Başkanlığı'nın
şirketlerinden prensin roketi top şöyle
bir şey söyle diyor ki fırsatlar kurudu
ve Elimizde 100 lira para var nereye
götüreceğini bilmedim Kağıt kaldı
elimizde nereye götüreceğini
bilmediğimiz Şu anda fırsat arayan çok
fazla vakit var ve bu fırsat çıktığından
dolayı bu para sahipleri çok zor durumda
dünyanın en zengin zengin yüzde biri en
zorda olan Kitle ve komik ile beraber
daha çok para daha çok vakit daha çok
motif girmeye başladı şimdi sıkıştılar
peki bu bizler için ne anlama geliyor Bu
ne oldu biraz Bir sonu demek arkadaşlar
ne oluyor benzin ediyordu çarlığı artır
enfes şirketi kur sonra başka fırsatta
yaratırsın sonucu artık bir sonuç şu
Karlı arttırdım arttırın o seviyeye
getirdim ki artık fırsat bulamaz hale
geldi 100 trilyon dolar kağıt haline
geldi kapıda duruyor Hatta bir tane
rakam daha vereyim geriye döneceğim çok
özür dilerim Mesela bu
ba ba satın 122 milyar doların şu anda
kasada nereye gideceklerini bilmiyorum
sürekli anlatıyoruz biliyor musunuz
Apple'ın kasasında 300 milyar dolara
yakın para varmış bizi de sormuyor neden
o para kasada duruyor Çünkü gidecek yeri
yok Google 300 milyar dolara yakın
parası var Neden kasadan Çünkü gidecek
yeri yok Çünkü artık fırsatlar azaldı
Peki nasıl bir yerdeyiz Bu ne demek
şimdi bu paranın hareket etmezse bu para
özellikle kol ile beraber daha çok yağ
daha çok rahat pompalamaya başladı anda
bu para nerede duruyorsa hangi ülkede
duruyorsa en çok ülkeye zarar verir
süper enflasyon demek buradaysa bu para
asla hareket etmek zorunda Peki biz bu
arada olsun hardan çıkmış Olsun zaten
şirketinin Küresi ortaklarından bir tane
Siz o ona Özellikle bu aralar bir zihin
haritaları çıkartmaya çalışıyorlar komik
ve zihin haritaları ve şeyi satmaya
çalışıyorlar bizim zihinlerimiz bu
duruma nasıl tepki veriyorlar özellikle
bir tanesi ekmekten bak
bu videonun simülasyonundan biraz Ödedim
ya En suçlu olan bizi sahnede olan ben
Ve bu TED reset izleyenler Çünkü onların
sapladı bir şey var ha patikler demişler
bizlere apatik segmenti öbeği büyüyor
apatik ve bir ne demek Bu arada şimdi
Dünya çok fakir o küçüklerin bir şey
yapması bu sistem ilgili imkansız hiç
bir fırsat vermemiş İzo insanlara ama
belki de var ki biraz daha küçük olan
Bizler iyi etimiz Kara yerlerimiz var
Birazcık para kazanırsınız baldan
birazcık attırıyorlar bize ama biz
apatik kalıyoruz ne diyor yani bu
sisteme karşı çıkmıyoruz apatik tepkisiz
kalıyoruz ve bu ödev ve bu benzin
simülasyonu birleşme veya ve büyümeye
başlıyor biz maalesef asıl tepki
göstermesi asla bu sistemi değiştirmesi
gerekenler harekete geçmiyorlar gibi
görünüyor biraz daha patikleri birazcık
da anlatacağım size şimdi bu aparatifler
sizlerin Eğer tepki vermemeye Eğer
harika
bu işlemi ve Atatürk durmaya devam
ederseniz bu ne oluyor bazı sonra size
nasıl dönecek birazcık size anlatmak
istiyorum hatırlarsınız ne demiştim
çocuğu orta yolun Yolcuları öteleyen ler
birazcık daha bekleyelim çok
konuşmayalım diyenler bizleriz
arkadaşlarım var ve bizler böyle devam
ederse bu sistem Öncelikle bize yeni
simülasyonlar yaratacak bize gerçeklik
Ötesi gerçek olmayan şeyler anlatılmaya
devam edecek girecek vizyonnet
olmadığını Hep birlikte göreceğiz ve
daha çok bu tane hareket etmesi için
2021 yılı itibariyle komik Bittiği anda
daha çok çılgın projeler daha çok
virüsler daha çok savaşlar Pardon
hareket etmesi için ve daha çok etkili
etiket ki göreceğiz onu etkiledi ketki
ne demektir hepimizin bedenlerinde kötü
genler olabilir ama bu genlerin hareket
etmesi için hayat şartlarının bir
şekilde kötüleşmesi gerekiyor ve Seher
hastalık genetik
Evet buraya çok hızlı bir sürü hastalığa
genetik gidiyoruz ya Ama bu gene
harekete geçip geçmemesi tamamıyla o
şartlara bağlı ve bu şartları
düzeltmezse queue orta yolun yolcusu
olmaya devam edersek eti genetik etki
ile karşı karşıya kalacağız ve kötü bazı
genler devreye girecek bir film görelim
hep beraber jeansen not yastığınızın
merkezde heybenin öteki adresi var mı
düt düt Yani eğer Hayret bir şey ya orta
yolun yolcusu olmaya devam edersek nasıl
sağlığımızı bozulduğunu da görmeye
başlarız orada kalmayacak hayat
bu olmak için bir tiyatro halde
dönüşecek kimseye Neyin doğru neyin
yanlış olduğunu bilmediği Tiyatro ve
sistemin o kadar parçası haline
gideceğiz ki bunun ötesini görmemiz
imkansız hale gelecek ya yeni
simülasyonlar geliyor Eğer buna karşı
durmayı öğrenmez sekeer neo-liberalizm
yerine yeni bir sistem yokken biz
buradayız ve biz aktivist düz ve bir
şeyler yapmaya kararlıyız demedimmi
sürece yeni simülasyonlar göreceğiz ve
bu simülasyonlar özellikle eşitsizliği
daha yüksek olan ülke eşisin daha yüksek
olduğu ülke daha çok etkileyecek Bütün
yapılan araştırmalar şunu gösteriyor
aslında bir ülkenin başına kötü bir şey
gelmesi için eşitsizliği yüksek olması
gerekiyor bakın bir ülke çok zengin
olabilir ama eşitsizlik varsa ayrışma
varsa toplum içinde yine çok kötü şeyler
geliyor başına doysam mevzu paraya sahip
olmanız değil mevzu parayı ne kadar eşit
bir şekilde dağıttınız anlamına gelir
onunla ilgili bir video göstermek Sağlık
olsun Sağlık olsun
bu endekste meşelik Sen gel Lojistik
Favorit şube Salih aşağı Hayır o
var yani ve ülkemizin ne kadar zengin
olduğu değil bilir ülkemizin ne kadar
tabakalaşmaya Karşı Çıktı ayrışmaya
karşı çıktı ve ne kadar eşit bir şekilde
zenginliği dağıttığını bakıyor şu bu
resme baktığımızda Türkiye'nin bu
dünyada birazcık şansı daha kötü
gidecekmiş gibi görünüyor onun içine
arkadaşlar baştan beri sonsuz ama
gereken şunu söyleyeyim baştan beri
Yapıştırıcılar dan bahsettim bizden Biz
yatıştırıcı Yapıştırıcılar Bu arada ilk
defa çocuğu şöyle tanımlamıştır eski
Başbakanı Ondan önceki başbakanı
yatıştırıcı olarak görmüştür şöyle
demişti yatıştırıcı için biliyor
başımıza gelecek ve elinde sonra
nazilerle karşı karşıya kalmaya zorunda
kalacağız ama yatıştırıyor sürekli
sakinleştiriyor ve şöyle bir Metafor
kullanmıştır karşımızda bir timsah var o
timsah sürekli yatıştırmaya besleyerek
atıştırmaya çalışıyoruz ta ki besleyecek
bir şey bulunmayacak kadar o zaman zaten
bizi yiyeceğini biliyoruz başımıza bela
geleceğini biliyoruz ama
İyi olmaya çalışıyoruz birazcık vakit
kazanmaya çalışıyoruz mevzuda Tam da bu
artık neo-liberalizm Sonuna Geldik
başımıza gelecekleri biliyoruz ama
sonucu biz ne zaman tepki göstereceğiz
Yani biz yatıştırıcı olmaktan ve o
ağzınıza çalınabilecek o azıcık o baldan
o kadar yerden o iyi eğitimden Onun için
ne zaman arkadaş susmaya devam edeceğiz
noktasında bu sisteme Dolayısıyla iki
Saydım kaldı ama unutmayın sürekli bize
sanki altına Türkiye'mizin olmadığı ve
statik koyu korumamız dünya ekonomisini
fatosun korumamız gerektiği söylenecek
böyle bir şey yapmayalım Aslında bazı
değerlerimiz var İki Sanayi devriminden
kalan işte rekabetsel değerler sınav ve
kariyer bu sistem Çok af Antalya bazı
ilk ideolojik kaygılarımız var Bunlardan
kurtulmamız ve yeniden başlıyor olmamız
gerekiyor yatıştırıcı olmaktan
vazgeçiyor olmamız gerekiyor birazcık
daha aktif hale gelmemiz gerekiyor çünkü
hepimizin Hakkı şudur
ya ben çok da biz yapıştırıcıların da bu
için savaşması getir dünyanın makul
ölçüde barışçıl insan uzaklığı arkadaş
canlısı ve Medeni kalması için mücadele
etmemiz gerekecek ve bunu bizden almaya
çalışanları önce anlayacağız ne demiştim
en başta ya anlamıyoruz ya da çok
başlayacağız bence Biz anlamıyoruz yani
sadece yapıştırıyoruz öte diyoruz
yapıştır özet ediyoruz önce anlayacağız
ve Bu sistemin bize yaptığı şeyleri
artık bağışlamak Tan vazgeçeceğiz
yapmamız gereken Yapıştırıcılar Bizler a
patikler dedin kitlenen artık ayağa
kalktı kalkması ve kendisini sahiplenen
bileceği bir aktivizmi inanması ve bunun
peşinden koşması Çünkü dünya bu sistemi
bip anı hareket etmesi için
hastalıkların oluşturulacağı
Savaşları'nın çıkacağı bir sistemi
kesinlikle haketmiyor ve artık
kaldıramıyor gibi görünüyor Çok teşekkür
ederim
abone ol